who
Lego The Hobbit is immediately charming
the title screen shows Bilbo puttering
around in his cozy hobbit hole of Bag
End and the wizard Gandalf poking his
head in the window as Howard shores
beautiful score from the films plays you
can almost feel the warmth from the fire
and from these quaint beginnings Lego
The Hobbit whisks you off on a journey
across middle-earth getting all the
visual details right to transport you to
the world of Peter Jackson's films but
despite the game's endearing Lego
characters its appealing sense of humor
and its faithfulness to the film's the
act of actually playing Lego The Hobbit
is a chore that leaves you firmly
grounded in reality all of the most
memorable scenes and locations from the
first two Hobbit films are represented
here but though it all looks
appropriately epic and imaginative this
is one sleepy quest as you make your way
through environments your progress is
constantly hindered and figuring out how
to advance is never remotely stimulating
or enjoyable maybe you need to just run
around smashing Lego objects until you
destroy the one that gives you the
pieces that let you build something that
lets you advance this building process
requires no ingenuity on your part you
usually just hold down a button for
several seconds as your character tosses
the pieces into place this is how it's
been since the earliest days of the Lego
games and the simplicity of the process
is getting tiresome occasionally the
building process involves a simplistic
minigame in which you see which pieces
needed to continue building the object
and have to select that particular type
of piece from among several pieces but
even the young children whom this game
is designed to appeal to deserve more
engaging problem-solving than this
you also often need to rely on the
abilities of one character or another to
advance you might need to switch to Dory
and use his flail to pull hooks loose or
perhaps dwellings hefty hammer is
required to whack a block into place
whatever it is there's never any sense
of accomplishment that comes from doing
these things because the game makes it
abundantly clear what you need to do you
don't need to think about it or play
skillfully to do it you just go through
the motions dutifully switching to the
correct character and using their
ability in the designated spot and then
there's the combat sluggish conflicts
that require no skill and have no
feeling of impact that dragged the game
down constantly again the presentation
does the film's justice combat sometimes
takes place amidst massive crowds and
even if they are LEGO minifigs rather
than highly detailed character models
the way the screen swarms with orcs
goblins or other foes makes these
skirmishes look large and alive and
dangerous when you face powerful enemies
the camera zooms in and the minifigs
perform stylish fight choreography that
wouldn't be out of place in Jackson's
films but as usual the chasm dividing
how the fights look and how they
actually feel is wide like so much of
the action and Lego The Hobbit winning
these battles is a matter of responding
to on-screen cues these aren't even
QuickTime events they're more like slow
time events
there's no shortage of content in Lego
The Hobbit the main story quest covers
the narrative of films in detail though
frustratingly it ends on the same
cliffhanger the second Hobbit film ends
on so there's no resolution offered here
and of course there are tons of
collectibles which we'll need to return
to levels as different characters to nab
perhaps using an elf's ability to walk
on tightropes or a goblins knack for
climbing certain walls there are also
plenty of optional side quests to
complete across middle-earth but they
all involve the same tedious mechanics
employed by the story quests Lego The
Hobbit proves that having plenty of
variety in terms of objectives and
gameplay mechanics doesn't make much
difference if none of those objectives
and mechanics are actually fun and that
capturing the look of an epic quest
isn't the same as capturing the feel of
one
[Music]
[Music]